CHECK OUT THE PIECE IN THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL." THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
MIGHT BE COMING.
CONGRESS FACING A FINAL DEADLINE
IN A WEEK PASSING A
$1.6 TRILLION SPENDING BILL IN
ORDER TO AVOID LIGHTS GOING OUT.
CHAD PERGRAM WILL HAVE A BUSY
WEEK.
>> GOOD MORNING.
CONGRESS AVERTED A WEEKEND
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN LATE LAST
NIGHT.
THEY OKAYED A BILL TO FUND THE
GOVERNMENT THROUGH
DECEMBER 23RD.
THAT MEANS THERE IS ANOTHER
DEADLINE TO AVOID THE SHUTDOWN
JUST BEFORE CHRISTMAS EVE.
>> WE'VE ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT IT
BEING A TACTIC.
YOU DO A CR NOW AND YOU ARE
FORCED TO BE AN OMNIBUS.
>> WHOSE TACK TAKE IS IT?
THIS IS SOMETHING WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE DONE BEFORE.
WHOSE TACTIC IS THIS?
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE DONE IT
MUCH SOONER.
>> ALSO LAST NIGHT THE SENATE
REJECTED A PLAN BY WEST VIRGINIA
DEMOCRAT JOE MANCHIN.
IT WOULD HAVE EXPEDITED ENERGY
PERMITS AND APPROVED A PIPELINE
IMPORTANT TO MANCHIN.
KANSAS REPUBLICAN ROGER MARSHALL
BLASTED THE AMENDMENT WHICH
MANCHIN WANTED TIED TO THE
DEFENSE BILL.
>> THE FINAL TEXT OF THIS
AMENDMENT ONLY SAW THE LIGHT OF
DAY JUST A WEEK AGO.
THE AMENDMENT HAS NOT BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF ANY DEBATE IN
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE HAD NO HEARINGS, NO
WITNESSES AND NO MARK-UPS.
THIS IS NO WAY TO MAKE MAJOR
CHANGES TO COMPLEX LAWS.
FINALLY, SENATOR MANCHIN'S
AMENDMENT DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
NEVER-ENDING ENVIRONMENTAL
LITIGATION.
>> MANCHIN WAS DISCOURAGED THAT
THE AMENDMENT FAILED EVEN AS THE
SENATE APPROVED THE DEFENSE
BILL.
>> I NEED TO RESPOND TO THAT.
I WASN'T INTENDING TO DO SO.
I WANT TO CLARIFY IT AND I HOPE
MY FRIEND WOULD LISTEN TO MY
CLARIFICATION.
IT IS IN THE BILL.
EITHER SOMEONE MAYBE HAD NOT
INFORMED YOU, SIR, BUT BASICALLY
THAT CAN'T BE DONE, WHAT YOU
SAID.
>> MANCHIN WAS PROMISED A VOTE
ON HIS PLAN IN EXCHANGE FOR
SUPPORTING THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT LAST SUMMER.
MANCHIN ORIGINALLY WANTED THE
AMENDMENT ATTACHED TO A SPENDING
BILL IN SEPTEMBER BUT A
COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY-CONCERNED
DEMOCRATS TEAMED UP WITH THE GOP
TO REJECT THE AMENDMENT.
REPUBLICANS WERE MAD AT MANCHIN
FOR SUPPORTING T